getting to work with Winona Ryder who
was one of the weirder and greatest
actors I ever knew like she was so
awesome and very strange in all the best
ways what's the weirdest thing Winona
Ryder did she sometimes would just we
would be literally about to roll like
okay you know that lights camera action
I'm about to start and then she'd be
like wait a second and then take me off
to the side and talk about I'm not sure
what
just like random random and I'm like oh
okay should we go back to the but she
was awesome we really is I mean she's
she another one who's just like that
camera rolls and you're like oh my God
she's so good yeah and was just lovely I
really you ever get Star Struck was she
was somebody initially were a little
star yeah big time